not to harp on this but to have all of
that success it's funny because when you
brought up knocked up your character
there were so many original takes in
that movie and the way that your
character talks to Leslie Mann you know
and the way you talk about women's
pregnancies and things and it was so it
it's funny because I found you to be
really charming and it's right on the
edge of very inappropriate and creepy
but I still was delighted by your
character and also I could see the the
women not being sure like he's on the
line but he's also strangely comforting
and lovely you found my secret weapon is
that like I can walk the line between
charming and creepy and like somehow
land and charming and we try to like I'm
doing this new show and we tried to like
utilize that because it's a guy going
through a breakdown this is not an uh
segue but we're trying this guy's going
through a breakdown he's still
practicing therapy on people
and I said to them at the beginning like
make him you can push him into
unlikability I'm like pretty confident I
can land him back in likable it's uh
it's fun it's like it's fun to get
pretty close to creepy you brought the
subs and and I want to talk about it
because you're playing uh a shrink
you're playing as and the show is called
shrink shrinking yeah and what I've
understood about the show so far is that
you're doing the one thing that a shrink
is not supposed to do which is because
of your breakdown you're telling your
clients you're telling the people that
you're treating exactly what they should
do as opposed to the classic tell me how
you're feeling what do you think you
should do yeah this kind of exercise and
keeping somebody in therapy yeah you
know what I mean and endlessly like tell
me your problem and we'll just kind of
pontificate on it there's a scene where
I'm with Harrison Ford and we have this
conversation I think is really true it's
like true when you're talking to a
friend too who's like dating somebody
terrible
and you can see so clearly that they're
terrible you know like just break up
with the guy you know you can say it as
a friend but in therapists I'm sure
having that same experience like oh I
know how to handle this like I could
solve this like that and so he just
starts he just starts doing it to
varying degrees of success and failure
what made you because I would you know
you obviously have a lot of
clout and time you can pick what you
want to do what made you say this is it
because I there was it some of it your
struggle or no I wouldn't say struggle
because everyone goes through it but
your own relationship too I want to be
happy that made you interested in
playing a psychiatrist yeah I think it
was that and also
um
I after How I Met Your Mother ended and
I did like a string of romantic comedies
I hit this period where like I said I
realized I wasn't wasn't whatever
everyone's telling me I had one life I
didn't feel that way I was trying to
figure it out so then I started doing
some dramas I did a movie called end of
the tour that you and I talked about on
your show once and I did a few others
and I delved pretty hard into drama and
and got I like to think pretty good at
it but at the same time I was like
and we are all so weird and funny like
you're not supposed to just throw that
part out and so then I got this call
from Bill Lawrence out of the blue
saying hey I'd like to make a show
together and when he and Brett Goldstein
pitched me that it felt like the end of
an M Night Shyamalan movie when it all
makes sense because it's a drama and a
comedy kind of mushed together this
guy's going through the death of his
wife and his own nervous breakdown but
at the same time it has like big set
comedy pieces and I felt like oh if I'm
gonna do comedies again this is this is
how to do it you know I do love that
we're in this era it used to be
um remember that was it like a fast food
sandwich that was the quarter pound or
something but they said it we keep the
the cold cold and the hot hot DLT bro
come on man
get with it doesn't make DLT bro okay
yeah because every American should know
that okay I'm sorry yeah I was Canadian
yeah and came here a few years ago I
didn't know that either Conan if it
makes you feel better yeah and you are
the the queen of fast food yes I am you
are okay I thought you're gonna say I'm
not from this country
you're from I almost said the island of
Altadena but anyway
um a storm a storm scarred Island
but anyway my whole idea is like the
tomatoes and the lettuce are kept cold
yeah we know how it works no excuse me
God it got hostile in here yeah anywho
the analogy I was trying to make is that
we there used to be an era where there's
comedy and then there's drama and never
the twain shall meet I started recently
as an exercise I just I don't know what
came over me but it was around the
holidays I thought I want to start
rewatching The Sopranos because I
watched it when it was originally on but
I want to see it again and try and
figure out what made it so
groundbreaking at the time and one of
the things that really hits me hard is
it is so dramatic but also so funny and
you never know which is coming yeah and
the comedy is really very funny they
don't indicate the comedy too much but
the characters are absurd and some of
the situations are are absolutely laugh
out loud you know uh insane and then of
course it gets extremely heavy and I
like that we live in this era yeah where
the two coexist you can make a show that
is you know I mean I'm thinking of like
a show like Severance where there are
times where I'm really laughing and then
it couldn't be more deadly serious I
like that we're now in that world where
that's allowed yeah I feel like Prime
James Brooks was that very much like
Broadcast News to me
it's like a perfect movie and even
within one scene
Albert Brooks is like imploring Holly
Hunter to see how much he loves her and
and to recognize it and then it's filled
with like comedic
assassination punch lines you know to me
that's always been The Sweet Spot yeah
and and almost impossible to hit Judd
told me when I was writing for eating
Sarah Marshall I asked him because I
pitched it to him first and and he said
this is a really good idea my advice to
you is write a drama
because of the way you see the world
this thing is going to end up funny even
in the way you're describing it it's
gonna be funny write a drama that's
what's going to keep people interested
and if we need to layer jokes on top we
will and I think that that's true like
I see the world funny even when I'm like
having tough moments like even when I'm
getting dumped naked I'm like God damn
it this is funny right and I can step
outside yourself see the silliness of it
and say I'm gonna record this for later
yeah well and I try to experience it
that way too because uh
I don't know
otherwise there's a version of life
being a real bummer I mean life's hard
you know so finding the fun stuff is
important I agree I I think uh I mean I
don't think a a day goes by when I don't
realize that oh I'm using my sense of
humor to cope it is not my profession
it's actually just my coping mechanism
that I somehow
uh in a houdini-like manner yeah figure
out a way to get paid for my coping
mechanism yeah which for most people is
like getting paid to drink totally
totally